good morning John I have a frustration
with one of the ways that the world
works the more attention and money you
have the more you can use that attention
and money to get more attention and
money which is the way that attention
and money consolidates this process
makes things less equal it just how it
works and I fall out of this trap
because I have more resources now when I
tend to want to push them towards the
things that we're working on whether
that's scishow or crash-course or dear
Hank and John as I will be doing that
next week for a thing that I'm excited
about this on the next week's dear Hank
and John if you want to know more about
it I'm going to right now turn some of
the attention that is on me on two
things that I'd freaking love one the
brain scoop just really loved it and
emily is amazing you haven't checked it
out lately do that to the Applied
Science YouTube channel watching this
guy tried to take a picture of
toothpaste with an electron microscope
is almost as entertaining as watching
him build a refrigerator that is cooled
by rubber bands three super Sam stuff
and also so many other vloggers that are
really good every time I find somebody
like Sam I get super excited for we're
gonna do some podcasts in the middle
here
Tannis it's amazing and creepy and
lovely and weird and I can't say
anything more than that without ruining
a criminal there's a lot of really great
crime podcasts out there this is my
favorite one personally six you must
remember this with Carina Longworth
she's so good she's so smart she knows
so much in the history of Hollywood is
so fascinating and also applicable to my
life and number seven my last podcast
humanised me which is a podcast of like
secular community building and also
other stuff by a guy who was formerly a
big deal in the evangelical christianity
community eight stephen sceptic and also
all of the other former sourcefed hosts
but Stephens content is so weird
and great and hilarious nine evylyn from
the Internet's who always makes me laugh
but also I feel very welcomed into her
content and also like it gives me a
chance to see stuff from a different
perspective 10-zip naff linguistics and
stick figures eleven Lindsey Ellis who
always makes me laugh she has a really
strong community and she always has
amazing takes on whatever content or
cultural things she's talking about
twelve this one video from a channel
that has a bunch of great videos but
it's called
how does do science it is the best video
that could exist on how science works 13
miles Chronicles don't
drink while watching this chant I mean
like any like not like get drunk I mean
like don't drink muled spray and choke
it's hilarious and of course no list of
underappreciated media would be complete
without the great gunnarolla there's so
much great creation in the world and we
are definitionally gonna miss out on
most if a lot of it's gonna happen in
languages we don't understand in
cultures that we're not a part of in
places will never go or see as an
example the first time I watched Hetty
in the background just for a moment I
saw this piece of graffiti the street
art and I'm a sucker for street art for
good design for cats and the image
struck me so hard that I was like I want
to talk to this person I want to put
that cat on a shirt and I want to sell
it I want this person to get paid where
they never thought they were gonna be
paid for the really amazing art you may
have even noticed me shouting into the
void of social media being like can
anyone get me in touch with this person
I tried like 30 different ways I got
within one degree of separation four or
five different times I talked to people
who knew him or had known him and
couldn't get in touch with him right now
and so I gave up I was bummed about it
but I gave up and then a couple of weeks
ago I got an email and in the subject
line nothing in the body in the subject
line said I am Turkish street artist
Katich is dead and we are now selling
his products on dftba calm there's a
week-long free order to different shirt
designs both of them on a unisex
or a woman's cut and also a lapel pin of
the original cat that I first saw I love
that are newly connected more global
society gives us an opportunity to see
more of the cool creations and for more
people to create professionally and I
think that we should work to take
advantage of these really cool
opportunities that this connection
brings us John there are links to all of
the things that I talked about that I
super super love down in the description
i hope that you people check them out
and love them too and I'll see you on
Tuesday